hello everyone welcome to this new video
by simply learn in this video we will
see how to use Google Keyword Planner
but before we begin consider subscribing
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
keyword research is a process of
identifying the words and phrases that
people use to search for information
products or services online This
research is critical for optimizing a
website's content ensuring it appears in
search engine result pages also known as
serps for Relevant queries there are
various tools to obtain keywords out of
which one is Keyword Planner which is
widely used among the digital marketers
Keyword Planner is a tool provided by
Google ads that allows marketers to
research and analyze put potential
keywords for their campaigns it provides
valuable data such as search volume
competition and suggested bid estimates
for each keyword this information helps
marketers to determine the best keywords
to Target allowing them to create more
effective content and ads that attract
relevant traffic to their website so
take a minute if you are looking to
become a successful digital marketer
then simply learn Sports graduate
program in digital marketing is the
right choice for you you will be
benefited with a detailed understanding
of search engine optimization content
marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
organization and match types keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn the number of tools like SC
ranking HootSuite Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube Twitter Google ads
Keyword Planner and much more so hurry
up and find the course Link in the
description box for more details our
Learners have experienced huge success
in their career listen to their
experience find the simply learns course
reviews Link in the description box so
without any further Ado let's begin and
start understanding how to use Google
Keyword Planner how to do a proper
keyword research so we looked at
Google's Keyword Planner tool in Google
ads and we typed in two keywords and we
were able to get a sense of what the
average volume is so we definitely want
to choose keywords based on the
following factors we want to choose it
based on search volume search volume is
a good indicator of the potential
traffic we can obtain so again for the
keyword homemade pizza to dough recipe
we know that it averages 2400 a month in
search volume again we may not get all
2400 but we're gonna get a line share of
that we also need to look at competition
and so Google's Keyword Planner gives us
a high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what I want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
Google's Keyword Planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
I want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what I can do is go
into Google search and I could type in
pizza recipes and I could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipe is
going to be included in this number here
and so I want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
I'm going to put in the all in title
syntax and so what that is going to ask
Google to do is tell me all the websites
that have pizza recipes the keyword
pizza recipes in the title tag so if I
do all entitle colon space then pizza
recipes my result drops down to 336 000.
so what that tells me is that there are
000 results with the keyword pizza
recipes in the title tag now if I want
to focus in on my other keyword if I
choose my other keyword was a longer
tail keyword homemade pizza dough recipe
so if I type that keyword in the
homemade pizza dough recipe or recipes
remember close variance and I just click
enter or type the keyword in hit my
Enter key I'm going to get 35 Million
results but but again is that really an
indicator of the type of competition I
have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
in title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2 160 different results so here I can
see the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites web pages that have that keyword
in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33 100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 000 so I'm going to
type in 683
000. what was our next keyword well it
was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is 2400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I typed that keyword
back in
2160. so I'm going to put 2160
so now I have an idea of what kind of
volume and what kind of competition I
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for a number of keywords what
you do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition if I make that a
percentage I can see it's 0.35 percent
is the ratio between volume of
competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111 so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
tier keyword homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able to do
that for a number of keywords and
examine the volume the competition and
the ratio between volume and competition
for your themed keywords in this case
pizza recipes so relevancy you want to
choose keywords that are very relevant
to the content that you're writing and
then again commercial intent what
keywords are going to drive more
conversions and revenue for the business
so when we talk about commercial intent
we're talking about you know are you
choosing keywords that are going to get
somebody to do what you want them to do
so we could say You Know download pizza
dough recipes so somebody's typing in
the keyword download pizza dough recipes
then chances are they're going to find
you come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the key word is it going
to help you drive conversions and
revenue if you're an e-commerce site so
search volume is the average monthly
search volume made for a particular
keyword and phrase so we can get that
number using Google's Keyword Planner
tool in the Google ads platform we want
to Target keywords with high search
volume that will help bring traffic to
the website we want volume but we want
to take into account seasonality as well
so that's where the Google's Keyword
Planner tool comes in place because if
we go back again we can just hover over
we can get a sense of any particular
Trend going on or season out so for
example if I saw a large growth in the
winter months and not much volume growth
in the summer months then that might
indicate to me that this keyword is more
popular during the winter time so pay
attention to the grass that you know the
Keyword Planner tool gives you use them
to your advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitled
syntax to find the competition so we
entered both of those numbers in and we
get our ratio and so when you have these
numbers for a number of different
keywords you want to be able to choose
that ratio of high volume low
competition but always relevancy always
trumps ratio so always go with a key
word that is going to be relevant to
your content don't choose a keyword
that's not relevant if you choose a
keyword that's not relevant it's not
going to bode well for user engagement
so the difficulty of a keyword ranges
from zero to a hundred and Google's
keyword tool so it's going to be easy
it's going to be medium it's going to be
hard but my recommendation is also to
get the numerical factor and that's the
all in title syntax and again relevancy
is what drives the traffic to your
website and keep the traffic there on
your website and also not only will keep
the traffic on your website but
hopefully get that traffic to engage and
convert so that's the key about
relevancy you always want to choose
keywords that are relevant to your
content even if it's sacrificing volume
relevant and see again Trump's volume
and competition so always choose
relevant keywords first so when you do
that you're always almost guaranteeing
that at some point somebody's going to
find your content because somebody out
there might be looking for it and if
they do you're going to get found and
then the engagement is going to be
better so understand your business find
keywords that are relevant to your
business and then focus on those
keywords that'll help you with getting
the right traffic to your site always
keep in mind the commercial intent so
these keywords are more specific and
result in conversion rate for example
buying is a good commercial intent
keyword so if you really want somebody
to come to your website and buy then
focus on those types of keywords in the
case of the pizza recipes maybe it's
download could be our commercial intent
keyword again there may be low search
volume but those are the type of
keywords you want to focus on because
that's the type of traffic you want to
drive to your site so some other
examples a commercial intent keyword
words or discount deal your coupon
shipping you know don't be afraid to use
some of these keywords as part of your
longer tail keyword phrase again the
volume may not be high but the traffic
quality is probably going to be better
so keyword research is the foundation
for SEO so if you have chosen your
keywords properly then if you do get
ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a second carry
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword you want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if our primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
the second Dairy keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keywords like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet plan weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I could see healthy
diet plan key word I'm focusing on is my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of 9900 and then some of
my secondary keywords healthy diet foods
diet plan weight loss low carb diet you
know Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan to go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan nine thousand nine
hundred what's my competition so my
competition is seventy four thousand
seven hundred and that's going to give
me a ratio of volume to competition of
13 so that's what my content's about
that's a considered a short tail keyword
because it has a lot of competition and
so my ratio is 13 and what I want to do
is I want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key
release two keywords I want to be able
to find my primary keyword that's
relevant to my content and then I want
to be able to find my secondary keyword
which is again related to the primary
keyword which is also related to the
content and so I want to be able to
choose two keywords basically and I want
to choose two keywords that are relevant
that have good ratio share between
volume and competition so that's the
whole idea again I'm how to do keyword
research you want to be able to find
your keywords use the tools available to
you and get a sense of what the volume
is what the competition is look at the
ratio between the volume and competition
and then based on the content choose
that primary keyword and then again
based on the keyword you chose choose
some secondary keywords as well because
you want to be found for not just one
keyword but multiple keywords so here we
wrap up this topic how to use Google
Keyword Planner if you like this video
share it with your family and friends
and do not forget to subscribe to Simply
learn thanks for watching this video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here